[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
welcome back to the break room our daily
show that keeps you updated on all the
nerdy news you need to know coming up
guardians of the galaxy three ant-man
three updates and
this wonderful panel starting all the
way to my left erika
yes joining us my fellow member of the
tom squad tom
[Applause]
why compete when we could simply join up
and become ultimate tom
uh
causing division in the tom community
angelica
hello
and finally to my right my right hand
man the paul to my john
the uh it's a beatles thing
no it's a jesus christ apostles
i was worried johnny
you guys we have some redemptions that
we're doing today um
we know comic-con is right around this
is so close we have on good authority
that we raised 300
today we will get a special video
appearance by eric voss uh we're adding
people to the slate daily um some of the
people that are on this panel might show
up and pop in who knows um if we hit 500
uh i'm gonna pull up my phone i'm gonna
call eric my phone is dying so we only
have a limited amount of time and we're
just gonna get his take on whatever
we're in the middle of doing whether
that be
getting so so donate where you want him
to uh appear whether that be uh talking
about ant-man in the wasp quantum mania
whether that be a scroll search segment
that we're going to be doing whether you
want his take on um
excuse me some guardians of the galaxy
volume 3 that's all we're talking about
today it's going to be a great show um
sorry to interrupt there no no problem
and we are starting the ticker at 53 on
behalf of michael sykes who gave
generously to have us call vos yesterday
despite the fact that we had said that
was not a redemption but michael i
always reward people that halfway listen
cause that's how i go through life baby
and that's why i'm gonna be single
forever
now i also
i came up with this didn't clear with
john but i'm gonna ask now a call to
action to all of our twitter fans i want
you to tweet at me or any of the other
break room hosts your break room cosplay
for comic con
and make sure you use the hashtag
comicon and make sure you use the
hashtag nr breakroom because otherwise
we won't be able to find you tweet at us
it could be regular cosplay you want to
show me your transformers cosplay that's
fine but if you want to cosplay as
brandon i want you to show me that too
and i want you to send it to me
comic-con
o t-o-m-i-c-o-n is the official that's
right comic con spelling except no
substitutions also the break room is on
tick tock baby that's right at the
underscore break room yesterday jess and
i released a banger of a tick tock
featuring the r2d2 screen that everyone
knows and loves so you can hear it in
eternity on our tick tock page now or
until jessica sues me and i have to take
it down so follow us for even more break
room content let's get to those
headlines make it make it your ringtone
while you still have time uh yeah let's
get into those headlines babies
you guys we've got one headline today
there's not a lot of news sort of
following us for the rest of the week
but we did get confirmation today from
adult swim that rick and morty season
six will debut on adult swim on
september 4th we're a little more than a
month out and if you weren't aware of
this i wasn't um rick and morty spin-off
show the vindicators show that that is
sort of a spin off of that season three
episode uh they did like ten little baby
mini episodes those are all out on
youtube right now you can watch
um it's a lot of fun yeah i think what
the answer to what everyone's asking
right now will eric and i be back with
rick explained and the answer is eric
certainly will will i be back that
remains to be seen we have an hr meeting
every week and uh i could be gone at any
time
who knows who will last after comic-con
to be honest we try to get rid of him
this week but he lives here that's right
rick splained will return though fear
not yeah yeah um i was kidding about not
having a lot of headlines what we're
going to do is we're going to sort of go
through all of the news for all the
properties that we're talking about so
we're going to recap a little bit of
comic con stuff
we did show this on saturday but we got
our first look at um
katherine newton's stature and and king
the conqueror proper the conqueror uh at
the uh in the new ant-man of the lost
quantomanium poster can we throw that up
there wow
look at that comic-con exclusive poster
you know if you if you're fans of the
ant-man franchise you might know that
they typically do like little tiny baby
uh little ants on a white background so
i'm sure we'll get that poster with the
addition of stature this time um
but uh really cool to see sort of like
classic kang look oh yeah poster um
we didn't get more uh too much more of
that we did get a like a little
description of kang's look in the
trailer footage that they showed to the
comic con audience didn't have a helmet
on in that footage didn't have
any kind of blue
face or anything like that but um
we'll see how he ends up looking like in
the in the whole movie um okay uh we
also had
catherine newton who's the new cassie
lang sort of talk about what her
character is up to in ant-man and the
quantum mania i want to hear from you
guys what you sort of think about this
really interesting
catherine newton said she is in jail
and she sort of couldn't believe that
they showed that in the comic-con
footage um
she said i love that that was the intro
to cassie first of all that experience
was so fun for me i couldn't even see
anybody but i could oh she's talking
about comic-con here but i could feel
everybody there um she says she's in
jail she's not up to no good she's up to
good um like father like daughter i
guess right they're gonna introduce her
uh
having been jailed although we did see
uh
the cassie lane character out of jail at
the beginning of avengers end game
hanging out at home so like what do you
think she's been up to in the
intervening couple of years where she's
do you think she's like stolen a suit
just like fighting crime i wonder yeah
maybe a misunderstanding
maybe she
uh maybe her father violated some sort
of house arrest and she took the fall
for him
you know against his will you know maybe
he was like cassie no and she was like
she did like some sort of magic trick
and he's like that's my girl
girl i'm mad but i'm proud you know some
teenage vigilante action i think she's
following her father's footsteps she
wants to be out there fighting bad guys
and doing all the good she's not up to
no good she's up to all the good she's
she's just setting up her disney plus
spin-off series in the future where she
fights yeah yeah
for the events
women have a certain stature
that's great
um peyton reed the director of ant-man 3
of course uh teased some cameos that
we'll see
in the quantum realm he said oh yes
there's great fun in store for everyone
and some surprising faces that may show
up in the quantum realm so yes we're
very excited that's what he said um
we're going to talk about uh a possible
team up for ant-man and the wasp
quantomania here in a second
but again i just want to get your guys's
thoughts we were talking about this a
little bit before the show tom you were
saying some stories you know the quantum
realm is sort of an mcu specific thing
but there's a very similar sort of thing
in the comics called the micro verse do
you have some folks you think might show
up in that yeah i was i was thinking
this could be one way of them setting up
the young avengers having their own
having their own movie uh because
they've already started setting up all
the pieces and and in the comics we know
that um you know nathaniel richards
right is uh or not it's an authority
riches one of the one of the richard's
descendants is the kang prime yes right
yeah yes and so uh they're they they're
probably setting up something for young
avengers i don't think we're they're i
don't think they're gonna have the whole
crew there but they might be setting the
pieces in stage so that once this movie
ends we can have
full-blown young avengers with the kang
i need names
uh well we're gonna have um uh the new
hawkeye of course haley steinfeld we're
gonna have um yeletta bulova black widow
so i'm sorry i'm sorry maybe i maybe i
was confusing he's teasing some faces
that are gonna show up in the quantum
realm um
and we saw that city sort of like as
janet was sort of blasting back
monopolists or whatever potentially
chronopolis yes um well then i then i'm
going to say that one face we're going
to see dr doom um
thanos in terms of them setting him up
setting him up especially with secret
wars uh now announced so i think we
might be setting up little pieces of
doctor doom showing up here and there so
who uh you know what capacity of course
we'll have to wait and see but i think
doctor doom might be or fantastic four
ish related characters are what's going
to be showing up
in this new this new quantum realm i
would kind of love it if there was like
we know bill murray is gonna be in this
movie i don't think he's gonna be cast
this doctor doom for a lot of obviously
yeah
but i would sort of love it if they
introduced a character that was not in
the comics and he was just sort of like
bopping around in different movies you
didn't really know what his motivations
were you didn't really know what his
deal was
uh you know
and then it is revealed that that person
is playing doctor doom just so that like
pizzas
the audience is sort of like oh [ __ ]
yeah
i was a speaking of pizza papa we didn't
we didn't run this as a story the other
day but uh bruce campbell did say he
signed on for multiple meds
i don't know
speaking of bill murray we did get a uh
well comic-con audiences got a look at
his character um no
crazy
weird look just kind of looked like bill
murray but he did say like
i think his one line of dialogue was
janet van dyne
he seems to know he seems to know who
janet is and there's a lot of
speculation that maybe he is someone
from the quantum realm
city maybe chronopolis and uh maybe had
a relationship with jenna she was in
there for a long time
yeah or he was her urkel running around
i feel like bill murray is so good at
playing that really casual but powerful
character so i'm sure maybe we can go
off of
i don't know a little bit of
that type cast here yeah you know and
then come up with some theories from
there i would love he's just playing
himself like he's
just like i don't know
he's always like that character that
doesn't really care too much you know
but he's also really powerful so i could
see him i love that like what if he's
got a new power it's like a groud hog
day power to the groundhog
[Laughter]
no it's real it's super real more
powerful than kang yeah look at the
piano i wonder uh in the case of bill
murray if he's gonna be
is there
any other
iterations of ant-man besides hank pym
and scott lang in the comics so could he
be another ant-man
well laurence fishburne's character
uh goliath was already sort of teased i
don't know the sort of ant-man verse as
well as some other people at this table
yeah you know that was an option i'm
sure they could also say like
yeah we gave him another maybe he was
like hank kim's old business partner or
something yeah he was the money man hank
was the science guy
but they made it work until they both
fell for the same woman
so we laughed exhale we were talking
about him being a good character we we
know that like modoc is going to be in
this film obviously kang do we think
like he could be
on the other side do you think he could
be a villain in this movie what if he
turns into modok i would
kill i'll vote
piggyback on what you said what if he
was uh he's just like old loki he's old
doom
he's been around forever yeah now he's
kind of a jaded bill murray kind of dude
who you maybe underestimate but really
he's uh he's dangerous yeah yeah cranky
old super villain i love that i could
see that like where he seems harmless
for the whole movie and then all of a
sudden at the end it's like
exactly cast as young bill murray and
future doctor doom projects that's a
heart
you know he casts nate from euphoria
my first pick for dude but that guy is
such a villain
his character's name is nate from
euphoria
see like a lot of his butt for some
reason
you can't blackmail me into dating you
um speaking of kang the conqueror kevin
feige said there was no one he would
want to shoulder faces four five and six
more than king the conqueror if you read
between the lines of that statement
which of course we will do uh we've got
kang in phase four with loki he who
remains kang in phase five with quantum
mania and we assume
loki season two uh kang in phase six
with at least kang dynasty
if we can we pull up that um phase five
graphic dash i don't know if we still
have it oh wow
quick draw back there there's a bunch of
projects on here uh he can only be in so
many of them right is there anything on
that list that you feel
okay we could get more kang in that the
marbles
the marbles
i'm like guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
okay can we can we get into that a
little bit
yeah i think well
similarly to guardians of the galaxy the
marvels have existing characters that we
know
right so having kang come in
and battling against the marvels like
we don't have to set it up to it like it
could just be
a variant of kang not he who remains who
is now dead but an evil king
could be
facilitating whoever the marvels are
going to be fighting against could be
hiding out is what the marvels are
fighting against because one of the
things about kang in the comics is that
it's often an identity that rev is
revealed to be king after impersonating
something or or literally not knowing
that they're king right right that's
interesting yeah we don't really know
who the villain is in the marvels we
sort of assume that it's going to be
like a scree scroll war type situation
but correct me if i'm wrong i don't
think that they've sort of announced
a villain in that not even other casting
huh other than the main three right well
there's the rumor that rogue is going to
be in it right
that was an early early rumor i'm sorry
that was an early rumor for captain
marvel 2 which is not a noun technically
yeah so that was an early rumor for that
i don't know that might have been
uh were you up for that
for rogue yeah
sadly i did not read for rome but i'd be
happy to read for any other rules
sarah haley finn is watching which i'm
sure she does
nothing but watch people
could you imagine hall h booing the [ __ ]
out of me
no
that's not my run
hashtag
i want to thank corey kandro for
donating fifty dollars
works
the
he
never gets to watch live hey welcome
thank you for watching us live from one
industry bro to another yeah
i'm sure yeah we keep you here for 12
hours every day just out of principle
that's right so i can't work yeah
otherwise i'd be a big star
i'm so sorry we do that to you uh i do
want to get back to what tom and i were
talking about earlier which is okay
kevin feige after comic-con was just
sort of talking about their upcoming
slate and he said you know we don't
really feel like these avengers movies
need to cap
the ends of phases anymore we're capping
them at the end of sagas so you know we
had the sort of infinity saga with with
phases one two and three we're now in
the multiverse saga they've announced
with faces four five and six and those
will end with two avengers movies he
said like we didn't feel like phase four
needed to
to end with uh an avengers movie like
they used to um but he did say like
you know we're still getting team-up
films like the avengers like multiverse
of madness like what we will see
in ant-man and the wasp quantum mania
um
you know obviously doctor strange 2 was
not a huge team-up film a la captain
america civil war or or any of the
avengers films but we did get uh you
know we did get juana maximoff we did
get a bunch of people on the illuminati
if you want to consider that sort of a
team um we obviously got america chavez
that team had a lot of cops
so that sort of got us here at new
rockstars speculating you know
okay we know we've got kang we know that
we've got uh scott cassie and hope um
who the hell else
is gonna be in this team-up film uh tom
i wanna come back to you since we were
just talking about it you think it's
gonna be a setup for the young avengers
we don't have any young avengers
anything on the upcoming marvel slates
right um do you think that they'll just
sort of like back door introduce all
these guys i think they might you know
and we've also known that they're saving
uh marvel and kevin feige are saving
things for d23 coming in and and there's
just too many players on the board for
the young avengers now you know but
between like wickin and you know wanda's
kids
you know and the new hawkeye america
chavez and all these new young iron
hearts about to come out they're setting
up a lot too many people that that need
to
that that that need to be uh you know
coming together to fight something and
in the comments they fight kang so that
would be a perfect opportunity i think
in ant-man 3 to have them at least
introduce themselves and join forces to
continue the battle or take it on to a
to their own movie which is probably
going to be announced maybe a d23 i love
your opinion
i feel like d23 is a great spot to
announce young avengers though you know
i definitely could see that um just
being like okay like we're setting up
for our uh
lack of better terms like a younger
audience you know it's like that's
perfect for d23 so and again there's the
roster so deep already i feel like with
these kids like how how much longer how
many more people are they going to
introduce to be on it and will it even
be young avengers because you know now
that she-hulk is going to be taking over
from bruce banner as we assume because
he's mark ruffalo's one of the og
avengers maybe it'll just be us another
kind of avengers team i don't know as
opposed to young amendments yeah she
hulk's an adult as opposed to the team
yeah yeah you know we got that
post-credit scene from miss marvel we
don't know where she went no it sort of
implied that she swapped places with
captain marvel i don't think captain
marvel was hanging out in the quantum
realm but there's every possibility that
for one reason or either these
characters could have slipped into maybe
the bangle is part yeah part of that
what the north you don't even know what
any of that is that's a good point right
right okay so let's run through the
young rangers lineup and you tell me
just off the cuff any of you can join in
yes or no for any of these people let's
start with miss marvel will will miss
marvel be in quantum media yes or no
i say no yeah
okay williams iron heart
introduced him black panther were kinda
forever
uh
i'm gonna say yes because of my theory
i'll go with it yes yes okay i like that
i like that i'm gonna say no okay yeah
okay uh uh
um yes um
yes
maybe but leaning towards yes i like
that
i'm gonna say no maybe because she's
been in a lot of stuff from the hawkeye
showed up so maybe they're gonna that's
why i wanna say yes
no
we just wrote there
uh who have i forgotten how about the
kids
kids oh what about um um sasha elijah
he's gonna be elijah bradley yeah elijah
brown oh elijah bradley
i think the young avengers group is
going to be really interesting i
personally don't know if that's who
we're going to see in quantum mania i
think we might go with the more sciency
people in the ncu
we were talking before the show maybe we
could get a bruce banner maybe that's
how we'll get a riri williams although
she's more sort of like on the
engineering side of things
oh you know one thing fun i just thought
of is um just like how we had the the
all the different um kang variants
coming out what if we see the council of
reeds which is in the comics you know
all the different richards
other a-listers because john krasinski
and kevin feige have kind of just said
oh this was a fan service thing yeah a
multiverse of madness doesn't
necessarily mean he's going to be the
read of mcu right maybe he could come
back for that again because it's like
another one-off and they could have
other a-listers be read written
oh my god
only played
variants of read but then in the mcu in
our main timeline there's a are the six
one six different ones this is a
completely different game yeah yeah but
it's rain wilson
all right well we're halfway to eric
voss uh appearing at tomicon virtually
uh
so and then we're well quite a ways away
from the old eric phone call which i
assure you we'll be inconveniencing him
so if you would like us to bug eric god
knows give generously because nothing
would please me more than to call his
ass in the middle of a work time yeah
how much do you guys love eric voss
prove it right now
this is your chance um i will say john
attend said instead of younger avengers
could be west coast avengers right
that makes a ton of sense i saw someone
say
uh
amadeus cho which would be interesting
um yeah we did think that um
um
uh
i can't remember um moving on
rj brown says kate bishop triple
seven triple zero
tva loki sylvia and doom so yeah i put
lucky in the thumbnail for this video
because i think with the kane connection
yeah
almost anywhere
you could totally get a silvie or a loki
only if they bring john mobius with them
you can get mobius in there it's the
west coast a lot of jet skis
like a group that they're gonna do for
secret wars right
yeah for sure
yeah um
uh
terrific i think uh chat i want to
continue to hear from you guys um maybe
we'll circle back to these predictions
at the end of the show
all right well we want to thank our
sponsors today our sponsor specifically
better help for sponsoring the break
room this week multiple folks on the nr
staff
have used better help in the past and i
am currently using and i have an
appointment scheduled for august 1st
hacking to my computer and listening to
what's going on in this old nightmare we
are big fans of taking care of your
mental well-being god knows the world is
a stressful place not be afraid to ask
for help a few folks at the channel have
even helped set up better help accounts
for their family members that had never
tried online therapy before and needed a
little encouragement it's a really great
way to help someone you love invest in
themselves that is for sure folks
sorry no problem better help online
therapy will assess your needs and can
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist in less than 48
hours i am telling you personally this
is how it went down for me i signed up i
filled out some information they said
that's enough you don't need to tell us
your blood type i said what about if
what if i'm in an accident i need a
blood transfusion they said then you use
a real doctor not a therapist
and then they set me up with a therapist
it took like i'd say all in 19 hours
took me five minutes to set up my
account they placed me with a therapist
i'm very excited about it you can check
out all the testimonials they have on
their website of real users sharing
their experience with better help
therapists and this is the really cool
part they have a special offer for our
breakers our roomies your trash bags get
10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
break room it's ten percent off your
first month of online therapy at
betterhelp.com break room use that break
room
code guys it helps us it helps you get
that 10 off and you know maybe uh better
help will sponsor us again thank you
very much now
i know we usually do mandatory fun in
this place
but i've decided today we're going to go
to work not the week of comic-con
comic-con yeah on the week of tomicon
it's still mandatory fun
it's a graphic
okay what a curveball
but today
mandatory fun is also mandatory
investigations
we got our first look at secret invasion
at comic-con and among a few of the
highlights don cheadle is returning as
rudy rhodes aka war machine
we also got a first look at amelia
clark's character and while we don't
know who she's portraying character is
certainly involved in a lot of action
emptying clips diving around
running for her life so
i love this by the way we got a photo of
familia clark walking around and i was
like oh cool she's not going to be a
scroll and then i was like what no
that's not how scrolls work
oh yeah good she's not a squirrel wait a
second
scroll
all right so
everybody put on your tinfoil hat it's
time to go cia mode let's figure out
who's in this secret invasion who will
be the scrolls each of you i've asked to
prepare a case file and present to me
and then put up on our big board who you
think is going to be a scroll let's go
left to right eric what you got for us
all right i love being first okay so
my first suspect of being a scroll in
the mcu and the upcoming titles is one
agent everett ross
i think where should i put this here and
there or anywhere okay any way you want
get him to the board we're gonna connect
it with red string boom okay so i think
he's a scroll because we won we haven't
seen him in a while i don't think since
black panther yes uh the original i got
to do this obligatory every time we say
black panther and the scroll to my
knowledge can't mimic powers that's true
yeah they usually
impersonate humans or non-superpowered
people uh and also who are in places
that can affect stability of systems so
agents government officials dodc people
cia people all types of people like that
so i think everett ross agent everett
ross is going to be a scroll in the
upcoming titles wow the other person i'm
suspecting of being a skrull in the mcu
and upcoming titles okay is one while i
vamp and try to get his picture out of
the file
jimmy
for the same reasons i think for
stability purposes uh the scroller
impersonating jimmy wu
and since he was last in ant-man 2 i
think he might show up or scroll jimmy
woo might show up in quantum mania
coming up oh okay we'll see if he can do
the card tricks slide a hand
yeah oh wait no he was last in one
division last time
yeah so yeah that's why i think these
two are prime suspects of being a scroll
wow
stationary spoken cheerio thank you for
your presentation
i don't think this is 616 canon but
jimmy wu is also going to be in the
upcoming marvel zombies series and the
marvel zombie series there's a scroll
biker gang so man
that's what they're getting at yeah
maybe that's where they get them
okay uh tom what do you got for us all
right fellow agents
i put together a very
very thorough portfolio full of two
photos
the first person i suspect to be a
squirrel is
sharon carter whoa sharon carter the
party starter sharon carter the party
starter and the power broker wow
that's what i meant the power broker uh
i was never
never on board with her being the power
broker i thought that that was
there was something else going on there
she's either working for someone else or
i just couldn't believe that she broke
bad that bad that fast
so i i i i gotta think that she's a
scroll there's something else that's
going on i think her her that end credit
scene of falcon of the winter soldier
was maybe her trying to collect weapons
or intel for the squirrel invasion okay
so that's why i'm going with sharon
carter
my next person my next suspect okay is
again similar to eric someone with major
influence uh who can help uh hook it up
behind the scenes make things happen
ayo oh oh oh
the
head dora milaje of black panther
yeah my suspect because
like eric was saying squirrels so far
haven't been able to do powers yet
but she is a very high level ranking
dora melange with a lot of influence and
a lot of ability to help take down the
most powerful country in the world
wakanda and if the skrulls were to even
have a chance to invade they would need
someone on the inside in wakanda so my
other guess ao black panther
okay i like it i like these theories
who you got for us all right it's my
turn all right agents
are we ready we are ready we're ready
i just have to
there we go
yeah
yeah my chair has boosted a little bit
um okay so i'm
thinking yeah that for our first scroll
here
is none other than
so this scroll obviously because they
can't copy powers uh is
very good with precision with you know
yeah that makes sense you just need like
a marksmanship exactly they got the
skills
and they were able to perpetrate it uh
when you went ronin i'm thinking you
know yeah like that's a framework well
you think that's when they kidnapped him
and turned to scotland
and he wasn't always a squirrel
oh i like that so that was like the
pivot here oh okay okay all right
that's what i'm thinking happened here
yeah scroll and maintain old guys
so drum roll for my
second
suspect
i think it's happy hogan
he's not so happy anymore
happy hogan is very very very sad and
depressed and he doesn't have the will
to go on anymore and that was when a
scroll came in
knocked him over the head and took over
and this is
you know obviously happy's got a lot of
influence here and so hogan yeah he's
from crappie hogan
hogan
i need to hear more of these scroll
versions
he does still have the stark like 3d
printer yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
i'll go next
and i've got some i'm going to blow the
door open
okay
i'll give you some legal stingers my
first
my first suspect is a twofer
it's the
bickering agents from the dndc
and stern-faced woman
whose name escapes me i want to say
was it like alyssa something it was
something like alyssa it was like a cute
little girl's name it's just stern face
now
anyway
it doesn't strike anyone else funny that
their relationship seemed to be a little
more than co-workers but it definitely
wasn't one of like i would say a sexual
tension it was like a
we're doing something else yeah and
we're doing this job stop averting me
and then cleary who seems like maybe
he's more of a talos style scroll was
like hey come on let's be good to the
humans and like figure this out and
melissa was like no let's kill him
so i think both of them are skrulls okay
the squirrel benson stabler of the mcu
oh yeah now
here's where it gets nutty
because i present to you
an answer to the question
where have all the x-men been and why do
they ignore
all of the avengers fight because
they're all strong
there's a scroll if that's true
all of the x-men are lame hyper sleep
scroll technology piper sleep in the
basement someone said under the
basketball court buried in the the empty
pool of the x-men x mansion for gifted
children
and then the squirrels are just living
in that mansion throwing parties
skateboarding i don't care all the x-men
are scrolls
john the floor is yours no wait have
they been scrolls all this time well
they were originally the x-men then as
soon as they got together they were
about to they had a press conference
lined up and then scroll invasions
like we're going to stay home and party
god didn't ruin my childhood so
if they were no no
all right agent staging john go to war
here agent john's getting
sassy
where is this we've seen him in one shot
one person one shot where's he been the
whole time what's he been up to his name
is war machine
exactly to break character for two
seconds i do think that there are
scrolls in the comics that can have
powers they're like oh they're super
scrolling
uh
[Music]
no team is complete without a leader oh
give it to me
and who better to lead the scroll than
valentina
i got to be honest guys that's a lot of
squirrel suspects now we all know i'm
definitely correct
so yes we're gonna have a poll in the
chat
and we're gonna decide between everyone
else's to see who might be correct i
just want to give a little bit of an
update we are
85 away from eric appearing at comic-con
and we are
285 away from us calling eric today
so uh that's on you guys okay eric was
so cute he really wanted to contribute
to comic-con if
i will say this i will have made him
record something for no reason
that will simply become something that
goes on our work slack that we all get
to enjoy and maybe we'll tell him we
aired it you know
what happened to me i used to have a lot
of juice
anyway good job agents yay also shout
out to john's amazing uh impression of
that one fish that screams chocolates
[Laughter]
um i did see some really ridiculous
scroll thoughts uh some folks from uh
from agents of shield people were
posting in the comments which would be
very funny if that's how they bring them
all back
but they were all scrolls oh my god um
uh oh the the poll ended early oh no
come back come on bro
um i i want to know from you guys so we
had nice scrolls in captain marvel
there's a change of pace we're getting a
secret invasion
we think i mean i guess we have to have
now like bad guy scrolls in this show
what do you think the deal there will be
are the cree going to be redeemed
sorry is everyone evil do we hate
everyone i think there'd be a faction of
evil squirrel that infiltrated the mcu
and they're all led on a mad conquest
for power uh but their general their
five star general will be none other
that's the one we've seen already in the
mcu this is
a new listen
they're gonna be led by howard the duck
[Music]
is
is starting to look like an early
favorite with 27.
okay wow this is like a haircut
jasmine victor though says comic-con wow
ensuring eric boss's involvement
we give okay let's let's do one thing
while we wait for this poll to end one
super powered individual that a super
scroll could be taking over we're not
going to include the x-men because
you've already sort of given all those
people one one superhero
from you guys yes either super soldier
serum weird radiation bit by spider any
of those things
can we kind of get a take from anyone
any of these people good
it would be nuts to see a cause i don't
know if
the squirrels have ever been able to do
this because when they do mimic powers i
don't know if it's ever been magical
what if we had a doctor strange
who could tap into
him
it wasn't nana who had the power exactly
it was it was skrull powers
yeah we could see a scroll with magic
that would be nuts okay
it was a tie oh my gosh oh my god damn
time wow
no i was just gonna say trey angelica
and tom you ty and your prizes you both
get vip invites to tomica
they're both invited to appear eric
because you came in last place you have
to appear time of god you have no choice
give us one hand take with the other
that's right i've been asking tommy all
day yeah and you're right finally i just
had to win a ball
he was really threatening
good scrolls
and speaking of who else is going to be
at comic-con we officially are well over
the 300 mark i don't know what our
adjusted total is now but a couple
people have given really generously in
the last few moments so we definitely
need to thank them at a certain point
but
eric will be at comic-con
and we're not airboss will be at
comic-con
[Music]
and we will certainly we're on our way
to calling him we've got 10 minutes left
if you want us to spend the remainder of
this show calling eric now is the time
i'll just talk to him about his wedding
planning absolutely we're getting into
the nitty gritty um we also wanted to
talk about guardians of the galaxy vol
3. mt has a video coming out on the
channel this week sort of breaking down
all of the footage uh that was shown at
comic-con and getting into the specifics
of the high evolutionary of adam warlock
of the final guardians of the galaxy
um but i wanted to run to some of the
comic con news that we got this weekend
just to refresh everyone's memories um
palm clemente uh the the actress who
plays mantis in guardians of the galaxy
volume 3 gave a little bit of background
on what her character's gonna be doing
this movie she says
that mantis has learned a lot more about
herself she's on a journey of
self-discovery she feels more
self-confident and more in her own power
and this is my favorite part of this
quote she said you're going to see more
of that and she's going to be like girl
more action dudes
[Laughter]
um i do love that like this is probably
the final movie that we're gonna get
with all of these characters so we're
gonna see their final versions karen
gillan has talked about how um uh nebula
is gonna be more herself now that thanos
isn't looming over her shoulders can be
really interesting movie james gunn has
gone on record saying it's his most
emotional movie yet which is like how do
you sort of out do i i every time i
watch the opening and closing of the
first guardians of the boxing movie
where he like won't touch his mom's hand
if she's dying
like fully melting a little are we or
does he mean more than slither yeah no
movie makes me cry harder than
our favorite scooby-doo live action film
monsters whatever monsters incorporate
uh
monster uh scooby-doo two monsters
unleash monsters
of course how can we forget uh he also
said that he's really not thinking about
the future of any any future guardians
lineup i think we've all sort of ready
for this i know it's really sad we've
all sort of accepted that this is
probably his final outing with his group
of guardians i haven't accepted it no i
actually haven't angelica is going to
direct emotionally
i haven't accepted it yeah
you know i think like by the end of that
movie we're all going to be in a puddle
of tears yeah i'm going through the
stages of grief already i'm prepping and
then the final one's accepted yeah
usually they have to like sweep up
popcorn and trash on movie theater
floors but this time they're just gonna
come straight in with mops
yeah you're saying you do and i was like
i didn't realize
that yeah
[Music]
he brings his own cleaning gear and he
goes you know what i don't work here
for the next show
listen do you guys appreciate the movies
or not yes
thank you thank you adds the sticky
stuff to the floor for the next
um we also got a first look at uh chuck
woody awg's character the high
evolutionary who's going to be sort of
the
the other villain the main villain
guardians of the galaxy volume 3. here's
some things that i found interesting
right he's got this crazy prosthetic
where it's like
stretching his skin face into a weird i
don't know what that is like a weird
mechanical
implement yeah
now the high evolutionary in the comics
is
sort of like all machines
i guess like
this is
i wonder if this is playing off of sort
of the nebula character-esque where like
you know he does a lot of experiments on
on animals in particular i wonder if
he's done some experiments on himself
sort of modification
either either experimenting on animals
to sort of like
get to a place where he can do them to
himself he's like oh cool animal testing
works
or if he's just a freaking weirdo
i just had a really demented song let's
hear it can i share what's happening i
do think like
those are my favorite
thing in a movie it's going to be a
james scott movie oh yeah yeah so you
know how taika said that he left the
goats with the guardians as a way to
kind of be like figure this out james
gunn nothing would be more james gunn
than rocket and groot
spitfiring goats at the beginning of the
movie
and they're like feeding an entire
village full of go like just so it's
like they're giving the village goat
meat like for years now it's quiet but
it also eliminates the need for those
goats to come back yeah that to me would
be james guns that would be very james
guns like are they feeding a village of
jamaicans like why are they
ghosts because they're hungry goats are
good it's uh spector knight i had the
same idea he looks like a borg from star
trek today
he is borg
can we talk about that that quote came
out before uh thor love and thunder came
out
and chris pratt is the one who said it
but but the goats don't end up with the
guardians
i don't understand why he said that um
and we kind of keep going back to it
because chris pratt said it which makes
you think
maybe
there's another one maybe maybe they
find them and they're like maybe their
throats
[Laughter]
you might scrolling down on who did it
because i can't read because it's behind
the cams you want you want me to go here
film juice
okay ross
gave generously and said if all our good
friend of film just now i can't read
i'm sorry i can't read if all the movie
verses are now part of the mcu
is xavier's death at absolute point he
did die three times
absolute points
gosh film juice why you gotta ask about
absolutely yeah right like uh wasn't um
god what's rachel mcadams character
christine was it christine palmer's
death an absolute point but then no
not but she's still alive well and then
yeah she's live in the eight one uh a
one one three eight whatever she's live
in eight three
[Laughter]
rachel's
every ludicrous song can be incorporated
with skrulls in it
because
we all know from this show use the
scroll
i said that use a straw
girl says tell john that guardians of
the galaxy volume 3 can take place
during the same time as thor love and
thunder you're just gonna clip out that
scene in the beginning and play this
beginning of guardians like yeah you're
gonna be like you wanted more goats
thank you to zaydog for both of your
super chats thank you to zeus13 who says
bring all the errors to comic-con oh
i'll invite every arabic i know my two
favorites are already going to be here
we are variants of each other
interesting question it's nina baby says
i love the channel thank you for your
awesome uh content thank you so much uh
when do you think we'll see white vision
again what is he even up to we
talked about this for quantum mania
is that what we're talking about this
for we were talking about it earlier
because viz had his theories about the
multiverse that's right that's right and
so maybe maybe he's looking for kings or
something like that i just figured he
was off having an existential crisis
you'd think he's just finding other
versions of him
staring at them until they break pretty
much what is white vision if not paul
bettany's acting job persevered
we need him back
let's see uh some people had guesses for
uh who scrolls could be
miguel ledger says
uh frog alligator loki red wing lockjaw
and the rest of the pet avengers oh
sorry this wasn't for scrolls this is
for people who want to be
very funny alligator loki scroll
confirmed yeah
wouldn't you choose the alligator yeah
yeah
nemo fish yeah i agree
his name was wait gus right gus
mick greenwood never missed an episode
but this is the first time i get to
watch live wow another person said that
and the earthquake under the ocean was
tama kicking in the womb we talked about
that we like that mick i also saw your
very good scott hall tribute in the chat
which i enjoyed say good night to the
bad guy uh
who else we got danny resicci says i
think the young avengers characters will
all be the main in the main avengers
movie
but they will be in their own subplot
okay
we're talking b plots c storylines how
does that work it's just like the kids
table um
but it is thanksgiving
go to a montage of them all making
dinner
wiping flower on each other's noses and
then they all sit down you pan down tiny
little kids table oh you you've got to
invite kang it's the holiday we'll put
our differences inside bill murray's
there but chaos
he's playing guitar on the quad thank
you guys so much for joining us today uh
here's what's happening for the rest of
the week uh tomorrow we're gonna be
diving into the second half of phase
five we're gonna be talking about agatha
covent of chaos we're gonna be talking
about daredevil born again captain
america new world order the thunderbolts
thank you daschle for bringing up the
graphic
um we want to cover all of the cool
stuff that's happening for you guys and
then of course you know what's happening
on friday comic con is being cancelled
once again uh if i have anything to do
with it that's absolutely not happening
comic-con will not be canceled comic-con
will be better than ever also don't
forget to send your comic-con cosplay to
my twitter john's twitter anyone who
works at new rockstars twitter with the
hashtag and our break room and the
hashtag tomicon or one of the other
we'll figure it out if you if you if
you're in cosplay like if you sent us
something of you dressed as like bizarro
we'll assume it's for comic-con come you
know what we might show some of the best
cosplays
maybe you'll be a part of maybe
comic-con is just all of us come on down
it looks in our hearts
all year long by the way we're also
doing a clip of the week we think the
craziest [ __ ] is going to happen on uh
friday but uh clip out something from
the previous week's episodes and throw
them up on our discord we'll be playing
that at tomicon at the end of the week
as well uh
you have to be 18 or older to join our
discord or you could not disclose your
age
chris hanson if you want to come on in
real fast
um in addition to that um we also have a
little voice mails thing so you can send
us a little voicemail if you have a cool
question anything about phases five and
six that you wanna ask us that we didn't
get to in the chat send us a voicemail
those are a little bit easier for us to
find us also on our discord go now what
are you waiting for the show's over get
out of get out of here